[Music]
all right alex is with us in
indianapolis hi alex welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hello it's a pleasure to speak with you
you too sir how can we help
yeah all right so my dad's been watching
you for a while and he kind of put me
onto you
and i've been watching youtube videos
for like the past year
and um i i i'm 16 and i work
uh i work at a restaurant and make
between 500 and
800 a month and i've been saving and
i'm really want to buy a 2001
corvette and they're about 10k
but my dad keeps telling me not to and
that is like the worst decision i could
make but
he said he would allow me and i just
want to know i want to get your opinion
if i should be allowed to to buy this
like with my current income because i
don't plan on going to college i'm going
to go to the military
and uh i i just i don't really see a
reason
for me to say right now and that i
should be able to buy this
well that's going to be up to your dad
as to whether you
are able to buy it or not in terms of
getting permission
that's not up to us i've got two
corvettes i love them i've got a 1960
and a 2014
both um and um
so i'm a corvette fan i love the car i
love the history um
and you know 2001's an interesting vet
it really is it's a pretty cool car
um if my son were 16
and in your situation i would be giving
him the same advice that your dad gave
you i don't think it's a place for you
to put your money
a 2001 is not going up in value
um it's going to at best stay stable
and uh or probably go down in value
so you're going to turn 10 000 into five
thousand dollars
uh and uh ten thousand dollars a lot of
money in your world
it's a lot of money in your world and so
um i i wouldn't do that if i were you um
i think it can be a goal later on
uh when you're you know an adult with a
full paycheck and you're in the military
if you want to go get you a vet
save up and pay cash for it whatever the
year at that point
but it would make a lot more sense when
you're earning a full-on
paycheck than it would now again
you and your dad get to make the
decision of what you all are going to do
in your home but i would
uh i would tell my 16 year old
in your situation with those dollars
that you're talking about
uh that that's not where i'm gonna put
the money yeah it's amazing too how
uh i think so often we feel like oh well
i can afford it so i should buy it but
it's like is that the best use
of that money especially in like you
said in your world when that's a whole
lot of money to you
yeah and well you only live once yolo
well that's true uh but you can screw up
your life while you're living it
yeah by yoloing around so um
you know you just got you have to stop
and look out and go okay
is the 26 year old you going to be happy
with the 16 year old used decision and
that's what i'm looking at
i don't think he's going to be happy
with you you your 26 year old version of
you is going to look back and go well
that was
dumb and so i wish that i had that money
to do this or do that with i wish i'd
been able to do that
and i had been a little bit more
conservative in my car purchase
at this stage of the game that's where i
would be but again
i will defer to your father he runs your
house
and uh whatever you all decide at your
place is there but i would if it were my
16 year old son i would
tell him not to do it because i don't
think it's a good play
thanks for calling in alex